oh it's a video room can I teach you a
trick you have to turn it to the side
yeah there we go that's how you do
it so do you like this
show C
it today ain't the day
okay
deep how do we fix this cuz this is a
very big problem I got this drink in my
cupo I'm out of
breath we just need to
simplify time is my biggest
obstacle it's impossible to not realize
how fast it's going when you are looking
through the eyes of your
[Music]
children I think about all of my heroes
and all that they
[Applause]
endured I know that all of my Str RM
sacrifice is opening the door for the
next they are the new
[Applause]
[Music]
beginning I have nothing to prove to
anyone at this
point we are creating our own
world
[Music]
this is my
reward nobody can take that away from
me thank God you
record what I just
did